the murals With This Heart you see look
to the first and there your next clue
will be the first letter of the name of
each mural with a heart on it will spell
out the clue
or some or something let's check out the
murals get ready for a full day of
hunting maybe even days plural enough
talking
Clues please and thank you
the treasure is buried beneath the
southwestern most bench in ramsit park
how could you have possibly figured that
out already once I determined the
cryptex was a false lead I realized the
hidden Clues on the Scrolls could be
solved with incomplete columnar
transposition the transposed words
alphanumerically linked to numbers the
sequence of which suggested latitude and
longitude then it was simply a matter of
accessing my mental Sexton I'm shocked
by the Indiana
5 out of five Sherlock
keep it and don't feel bad it's my curse
Leslie thanks to your annoying prying
last year I'm sure you remember my
birthday is coming up I know I know no
parties you hate parties correct
oh you know that wild goose chase you
sent been on for Valentine's Day the
scavenger hunt I also do not want that
yep I understand I absolutely do not
want to solve a series of riddles and
clues each more intricate than the last
you understand what I'm saying you had
it run
good
I I do want that please do that for me
sugar that the average Pawnee
ten-year-old consumes from soda every
month that is gross gross all that Sugar
it's really gross what a powerful image
what are you doing what did you put in
the sugar it's so good the key is you
have to keep yourself busy or else
you're going to go crazy I mean look at
me look how busy I am I'm inventing a
new spice called solger it's part salt
part sugar
what could that possibly be good on
butterscotch pudding fair enough
I love me at calzone and going crazy
first thing won't let me work in the
parts department now they won't let me
campaign either all I want to do is
improve our town and they won't let me
do that putting an awful lot of sulga on
your pasta
sugar
coffee in the morning oh my God
I hope you don't mind we decided to
throw you a pizza party to say congrats
for cracking the case
God you guys let's see what we got here
wait a second that's not pizza those are
calzones
that's the right choice
what's up guys
[Applause]
Wyatt you're late
I'm just kidding you do whatever you
want
actually Barney I'm afraid I have some
bad news
today's my last day I got an opportunity
I couldn't say no to and I have to quit
again I need to explain
I know this too good to be true
oh I do have a little going away gift
left it in the break room
if anyone could appreciate it it's you
guys
you can play with one Warrior but it's
just not nearly as good enjoy Ben Wyatt
let's play
no no it's not as good as the other one
I don't know what you mean by good
neither do I just do another one
you know I have actual assignments that
I have to finish for art school Shut up
and do more art for me
this one's racist
it's beautiful
I've looked at this for five hours now
I like the green one
the red circle right here
tear it up man
oh wow that is really good Andy no I'm
sorry this tastes great all my favorite
foods have butter on them pancakes toast
popcorn grapes
butter is my favorite food well then
you're gonna love what I'm churning up
take a look at oh my God this is
horrifying nobody eat that
wow really good Jerry
for my urinal I was inspired by the
death of my grandma you said mural
yes you did you said
anyway she
people get marinade all over it Jerry go
to the doctor you might have a urinary
tract infection
this one is
yeah
it's pointillism
and each dot is a photo of a citizen of
the town
Jerry
oh my gosh look who's here Leslie the
nightmare's over Jerry we're going back
to work you're not gonna need this
anymore
yeah
Perkins
Jan Perkins your expertise is thrilling
and frankly almost arousing and Perkins
and Perkins and Perkins maid of honor
and Perkins has terrible taste in rings
and Perkins oh hi Ann Perkins hi
and Perkins
is that a happy yeah
or is that a bad news and Perkins oh
happy obviously the bad news one sounds
like this
and Perkins
oh hey and Perkins hi and puppets
goodbye and Perkins my excellent
employee hello Ann Perkins my fallopian
princess and Perkins you really know
your testes and Perkins and Perkins and
Perkins and Perkins
convergence the receptionist social fit
you in as soon as there's an opening if
you're all right I'm gonna head back to
the park real quick do you know what my
social security number is or if I'm
allergic to anything I don't like corn
should I put that down or will that be
confusing because I do like candy corn
oh Ron what a mess
here let me help you all I wanted was
two hours where I got to forget that I
was a parent look I found all three
differences those are two completely
different pictures
why are you here
come back to work
nah
come back
I want you to come back well I don't
want to come back
the end I was talking to Andy about you
and he made me realize that I need you
back at work what did he say don't
recall fine I'll come back
good
okay I'm leaving
bye Zuzu
bye Duke silver
my mom has all your albums
I recognize you the day we met
have you told anyone no
good girl
thank you Commissioner Gordon people of
Gotham okay she thinks she's in Batman
people often ask me Joan how do you do
it
I love being on TV what are we gonna do
guys how are we gonna get that money hey
come on cheer up little pups registering
for your wedding is the most important
moment in your lives love love Fades
away but things
are forever that's beautiful did the
Dalai Lama say that oh a citrus reamer
ah this is the only way to remove Citrus
you're gonna need two of these I don't
want a citrus reamer I don't want any of
this stuff look all I want is to be
married to you and to somehow get fifty
thousand dollars
hang on
what if we register for the park instead
of this stuff we could organize a black
tie Gala with food and music and maybe a
silent auction to raise money yeah
people could donate or they could bid to
put their names on everything in the
park like benches cobblestones trees
ants Air right some of that is possible
you're a genius let's go okay hey guys
I'm really feeling these sheets very
cozy
oh my God Jerry when you
and Ty please go to yahoo.com well how
else would I do it you don't have your
email bookmarked do you have any
bookmarks what's bookmarks God Jerry you
don't deserve the internet I once forgot
to brush my teeth for five weeks I
didn't actually sell my last card I just
forgot where I parked it I don't know
who Al Gore is and at this point I'm too
afraid to ask when they say two percent
milk I don't know what the other 98 is
when I was a baby my head was so big
scientist it experiments on me I once
threw beer at a swan and then it
attacked my niece Rebecca that'll do
Andrew
foreign